se esperaba que estas jornadas en las
cuales se recuerdan los 40 días después
del fallecimiento de muchas de las
personas que fallecieron al comienzo de
las protestas fueran multitudinarias que
muchas personas asistieran a los
cementerios acompañar a sus familias y
allí se cantarán eslóganes sin embargo
creo que nadie esperaba en Irán
especialmente las autoridades que hace
una semana habían dicho que las
protestas se daban por terminadas así lo
había dicho el jefe máximo de los
guardias revolucionarios que le dijo a
los jóvenes que no salgan a la calle no
esperaban esta movilización tan grande
en el día de hoy estas se dieron en
ciudades importantes como isfahan
también como Jazmín en el norte pero
especialmente en una ciudad que es la
capital de la provincia de albox pero
que también opera como una ciudad
satélite de Teherán a una hora de la
capital donde se consigue un gran gran
número de personas se dice que al menos
500 personas intentaron unirse para
llegar al cementerio fueron detenidos
por los ataques de las fuerzas de
seguridad y comenzaron grandes
enfrentamientos que incluyó la quema de
un carro policial de un kiosco donde
está la policía y también un miliciano
al menos un miliciano conocido como
basilla habría muerto otros tres
policías habrían sido fuertemente
atacados y también se habla de otros dos
muertos aunque no se sabe si eran
personas que estaban en las protestas o
eran parte de las autoridades